Coming this year.
This is about everything to the Hulu Disney
Plus book.
This is why we're perfect together.
Hang on.
And the key features on Disney,
plus different things.
This is just the beginning and stories
you'll love on Hulu.
What did you say?
It's testing.
Love it
with Disney Plus Better Together in 2023.
So brilliant spot on all of this and more.
You're ready for an adventure.
Oh 2023 on Disney
Plus it's going to be quite a year.
New stories. This is just the beginning.
Definitely new faces
to be expecting someone else
and some familiar ones to hang on.
Like this handsome fellow
all over the top, don't you think?
There's only one place
that's home to all of this.
And so much more.
Disney Plus.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie Marvel released a bunch
of new trailer scenes from Loki Season
two, The Secret Invasion Nick Fury series,
Even The Mandalorian Season three.
I'll start with the new Loki Season
two footage
just because of the big connection
to Kang the Conqueror, Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania is coming out
right now.
Everything is building
towards Avengers five, Kang Dynasty.
But The Mandalorian Season three
and the Secret Invasion
episodes will both come before Loki.
Season two episodes.
Of course I will do videos for everything.
It's going to be awesome.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the because Ant-Man
and the wasp
Quantumania is also coming out.
We're doing an IMAX ticket
giveaway for that.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your predictions for Kang
in Loki Season two in the comments
and we're going to get a bunch of
new Marvel Super Bowl trailers too.
Of course
I'll do videos for those as well,
but they'll be a little bit different.
Like there's not going to be a Loki Season
two trailer.
They'll be like, Marvel's A new Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania trailer,
a new Guardians of the Galaxy
three trailer,
which is starting with the new Loki Season
two footage.
The big thing here
is that they want to show you
what's happening
at the beginning of Loki. Season two.
This is Loki talking to Mobius inside
one of their cafeterias.
This designed like a classic automat,
like a classic British automat,
because everything in the TVA
has this very particular design style
that makes it look old timey, even though
technically nothing actually ages
in the TVA because of the way that Kane
controls the flow of time in there.
In the scene, he's talking to Mobius
about their current predicament.
It's meant to be a parallel
for their scenes during season
one in that version of the TVA's
lunch Room,
where they work through the problem
how to find Sylvie
before they knew who or what Sylvie was.
The next scene is of Loki
in another new room in the TVA,
trying to explain something being held
at the mercy of some other attendant here,
like some of the receptionist.
And this is meant to be
a funny scene of him
getting exasperated with someone
who's not listening to him,
like the assistant in someone's office
who just forces you to wait
for some important meeting.
You're there for this scene of Loki
with the severed head of the timekeeper
robot is with Mobius,
the other two agents nearby.
And they're just out of frame.
This is one of the scenes
they released in the D23 trailer
but didn't allow online in the scene.
It's still early in the series
when Loki is trying to explain
everything that happened in season
one to Mobius, the other TVA agents
who are part of the new timeline created
after he remains.
Kang was killed by Sylvie in the timeline
rebooted.
None of them have memories
of what happened
during season one,
except for robot translator.
She's not here in any of this footage.
She escaped during season one,
but she will be back during season two.
In the scene is meant to play out like
a faster version of the Big Timekeepers.
Kang revealed during season one,
where Loki uses
one of the quantum energy batons
they use to prune things to destroy this
wall, a mural depicting the timekeepers
holding the sacred timeline like it's
a mural version of the video that he had
to watch at the beginning of season one.
He destroys the outer mural here to reveal
another giant golden statue behind it.
Kind of like the statues
of the timekeepers above Rana translator
in her judges desk, only a giant golden
one revealed by him destroying this wall.
And it's supposed to be the Kang
the Conqueror that's meant
to be ruling over this version of the TVA
in the new rebooted timeline.
You notice he looks a little bit different
from the variant of Kang
the Conqueror that we see in Ant-Man
and the wasp.
Like he doesn't have the scars.
His haircut is very different,
so I think it's meant
to be a different Kang variant in Loki.
He's trying to prove that
what he's been yelling about
with the Kang variants,
the Kang multiverse war is true
because at first nobody believes
so they just think that he's crazy.
But part of the idea
during Loki Season two
is that when Sylvie sends him back
to the timeline that has rebooted the TVA,
this Kang is currently winning
the K Multiverse war created the TVA,
but he's mysteriously missing from the TVA
in the same way that during season one
you didn't really see he who remains
until the end of the season,
even though his presence
was felt everywhere.
I think the idea they're implying
with this new Kang variant during
Loki season two
is that the Kang Multiverse war has been
raging again with the Council of Kangs
fighting each other
and separately infinite
other rogue variants of Kang
are fighting everyone for supremacy.
All on top of that
in the variants of Kang that was running
the TVA here is busy with that.
Like he's
fighting the Kang Multiverse war,
so he's not around for minor day to day
stuff, leaving the TVA agents like Mobius
Hunter, B-15,
everyone else to figure out what they're
supposed to be doing all the time.
That's one of the reasons
why they were yelling
at the end of season one, like,
everything's crazy.
What are we supposed to be working on?
He hasn't told us because he's not around.
He's busy
fighting the Kang Multiverse War.
But while there's a larger mystery
about the Kang Multiverse War
and the Kang variant is going on,
the TVA agents, all these people are still
doing their regular day to day missions.
They're still going around
pruning dangerous variants and nexus
events like Mobius of the TVA
are still doing what they would
normally be doing every day.
That's one of the reasons why
they get involved in the plot of Deadpool
three because Deadpool and Wolverine
Wind up running afoul of Mobius, the TVA.
In most minutes
I've been talking about Deadpool three
being like them,
doing a version of Deadpool kills
the Fox Marvel Universe with him
messing up the Fox timeline
because of all the time
traveling he's doing.
That's what we'll put him on.
Mobius and the TVA's list.
They're going to be shooting Deadpool
three for most of this year,
so we'll get some more footage
of that pretty soon.
This thing of Loki using his magic
to fight people is him just fighting other
TVA agents using one of those same batons,
but he's also using his magic.
That's why you see the green flash.
As you can see, the building behind them
is meant to be similar architecture
from the TBA.
This is just happening.
And one of the other new TVA buildings.
The next much bigger scene is in the back
alley of a special theater
where they've come to stop a new Nexus
event involving the Zanier character
from Marvel Comics.
I've already done
a longer video about this
because we saw a bunch of
footage from this
and there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
for all the fake movies
inside the Marvel Universe.
But the reason why they're dressed
in tuxedos that look like that
all old timey is because
this is taking place in the 1970s, London
Like they actually go back in time
to stop the Nexus event.
And it's at this movie
premiere at this London theater.
And in the scene, you probably recognize
Loki is using the same magic trick
that he used in the first Avengers movie
to duplicate himself with illusions.
And Mobius is just making fun of him.
Like, isn't this a bit much?
You like being a bit showy,
even though that's totally Loki's style
to be super showy and over-the-top,
because the movie that's premiering
here is the Zany Act movie,
which itself is a comic book character.
So it's like a reference
within a reference without a reference.
So it's a very meta episode
because Maniac himself
is sort of like a parody on comic book
characters inside the MCU.
And at this particular movie theater,
there's a bunch of those fake in universe
MCU movies that themselves are references
to other real life Marvel movies.
I'll post a link in the description
for my other longer video on that
because there are a lot of Easter eggs
in different parts of the scene
that they didn't include in the trailer.
Like Kingo's original movie
is also playing at this movie theater
because this is in the 1970s.
Then they're in another new room
revealing the K Kwan from
everything everywhere, all at once
is playing a brand new character.
They actually brought him on stage
during the D23 presentation,
like Guess Who We Got?
They said that he's playing
a TVA archivist in the room they're in.
Just seems like an archives room
where they store
really
dangerous are really important items
that they don't just outright destroy
or send to the trash planet
in Loki makes in everything everywhere
all at once.
Reference.
He says this is about everything
during this scene while they cut this
in the trailer in the last scene, he's
falling between buildings inside the TVA,
screaming the whole way down like business
as usual for Loki, same as it ever was.
Seems like a disaster
that he's totally failing at,
but somehow manages to pull off a win.
The new Secret invasion
trailer footage is of Emilia Clarke
character talking to Nick Fury
about this evil faction of Skrulls,
which they also show separately, saying
that this is just the beginning of like
they're uncovering this big conspiracy
that this evil faction of Skrulls
is trying to pull off, trying to take over
Earth just like comic books.
Secret Invasion.
There are rumors now that she's actually
playing Taylor's daughter, and that's
her connection to Nick Fury in TALOS,
like why Talus would get involved.
We also see the footage of Everett
Ross helping Nick Fury,
but he's sneaking around
because now he's a fugitive from the law
because the coyote broke him
out of federal custody
at the end of the Black Panther.
What kind of forever movie, Which they
also show footage of during this trailer.
The whole idea during that movie
is that Everett
Ross was trying to help the Condon's,
and Val wanted to arrest him
because they're setting her up
as this bigger villain,
like a dark version of Nick Fury,
who is now in charge of the CIA
and using that power to just go rampant.
That's part of a larger plot
that's going to culminate in the
Thunderbolts movie in Captain America
four New World Order with Red Hook.
It sounds like they're actually going
to introduce a version
of the century in the Thunderbolts movie
or maybe even Squadron Supreme.
And now Henry Cavill is totally available.
Like he got fired as Superman.
He's totally available
to play a marvel character.
I don't actually think that he's
going to wind up playing a
dark version of Superman in a marvel movie
like Hyperion or even the Century.
If he does show up in a marvel movie,
he probably plays
somebody completely different.
There've been a lot of questions
about who Emilia Clarke is playing.
There have been a couple big theories,
so we'll wait for more trailer footage.
Maybe we'll get some more clues
about that.
I've heard that she's both playing
one of the scrolls, like she's playing
Taylor's daughter.
I've also heard that she's playing
a version of Abigail Brand, completely
different character,
but part of Sword in the comics.
Hopefully the next trailer
will just clarify some of that.
There is a new Mandalorian Season
three trailer footage in here.
I've already done
a couple separate videos about that.
That series will be the next one
to air episodes starting
at the very beginning of March.
I don't expect a new trailer for that
at the Super Bowl,
but we might get some new footage
next week
or in the next couple of weeks
just because it's so close.
Congratulations, Rabb.
Like you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video. Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
And yes, we will see a bunch of different
types of variants of Kang, some of them
worse than others, some of them genuinely
good, wanting to help them all.
Talk more about all the different Kang
variants.
The Council of Kangs in My Future, Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania in Loki Season
two videos,
we're supposed to see multiple different
variants of Kang during Loki Season two.
Everyone click here
for my new Quantumania video to watch Kang
Start the Multiverse War.
That's right.
He's the one that started the multiverse
war and click here for that Black Panther.
What kind of forever deleted
scene with more secret invasion,
Easter eggs and connections.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.